حكومه هناك الياهو نحو التصويت لصالح
الغاء ما يعرف ببند المحوريه الذي يعد
جزءا من التغييرات القضائيه التي تسعى
حكومه نتنياهو لاقرارها كان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات الى
اين ياخذ تصويت الكنيست والخلاف بشان
التغييرات القضائيه وكيف نقرا تمسك طرفي
الخلاف بموقفهما وفشلهما لحد الان في
الذهاب نحو الحوار والى اين تذهب الاوضاع
السياسيه والامنيه في اسرائيل
بالنهايه ذهب الى اقرار بند المعقوليه
لانه كان يعلم انه اذا الغى هذا البند او
اجله فانه تمته كانت سوف تسقط الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الان قرات بند المعقوليه ولكن
عينها على بند اهم منه وهو باند يتعلق
بلجنه تعيين القضاه في المحكمه العليا
جوهر ما يجري هو بالضبط ما تنبا به كثير
من الحكماء منذ سنوات بان الاحتلال خلق
الاستيطان والاستيطان خلق نظام العنصري
ونظام الابرتايد العنصري انتج الفاشيه في
اسرائيل لكن هناك رد فعل الامريكي قوه
بالعكس هناك نوع من عدم الضغط على نتنياهو
سمعنا بالامثل هناك محادثه تليفونيه بين
تنياه وبين بايدن لم تسفر عن شيكا ما حدث
الامر في السابق الان اسرائيل بالتصويت
على هذا البند هي عمليا هي الغت اي رقابه
لسلطه القضائيه على السلطه التنفيذيه لان
ما يجري هو بالضبط السرطان سرطان الاحتلال
والعنصريه الذي يلتهم اسرائيل من الداخل
كما توقع كثيرون والفرصه العظيمه التي
تنشا امامنا الان هذا سبب اضافي لتوحيد
الساحه الفلسطينيه
والذي نراه اليوم تحالف عميق بين الفاشيه
الصهيونيه اليهوديه المتطرفه المتعصبه
الاصوليه مع اللصوص والمحتالين في هذه
الحكومه هذا اليمين يريد ان يحسم دوله
اسرائيل بمعنى يحسمها بانه يريد ان يبنيها
من جديد بما يتوافق مع توجهات
الايديولوجيه وهذا جزء من الغرور الذي
اصاب اليمين في السنوات
ليس كتله واحده هناك لوبي دعم
بعضهم حتى يؤيد الامير مضطرب داخل اسرائيل
لكن ايضا هناك ما يسمى بالاثار اليهودي او
اليسار الامريكي اللي هو الذي شكله باخر
يدعم ابو وجود دوله ليبراليه علمانيه على
غرار الدوله الامريكيه لان اليمين يعلم ان
السلطه القضائيه هي واحده من العقبات التي
تقف امامه في بعض الاحيان امام مشروعه من
اجل تهويه دوله اسرائيل واحتلالها لماذا
يريد تخريب القضاء لانهم يريدوا ان يهربوا
من المحاكمه سواء نتنياه و المتهم بالفساد
او درعي الذي يريدون ان يعيدونه الى ان
يعيدوه الى الحكومه اليمين لا يريد ان لا
يريد اي توافق يريد ان يحسم هويه دوله
اسرائيل نسبه لليمين هذه الحكومه هي فرصه
تاريخيه للجنين الازمه عميقه ولن تحل حتى
باتفاق بين المعارضه يحكموا
التداعيات لهذا التغيير الدستوري يتداعيات
عميقه جدا نتنياه ربي الجوله الاولى ولكن
هذه الجوله سيكون لها ثمن ضاهد على
اسرائيل على المستويات العسكريه والامنيه
والاقتصاديه والتكتل الاجتماعي الداخلي في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي الازمه عميقه جدا
وسيكون لها تداعيات خطيره وابرز هذه
التداعيات لانهيار في الجيش التداعيات
العسكريه هي خطيره جدا ونتنياهو من خلال
كلمته حاول ان يخفف منها ولكن هذا يخالف
كل التقديرات الاسرائيليه وكل تقديرات
الاركان السابقين والرسائل الاجهزه
الامنيه والاستخباطيه ان الوضع في داخل
جيش الاسرائيلي هو خطيه يعني ثلثي جيش
الاحتلال هو من جنود وضباط الاحتياط
وهؤلاء الذين يتمردون الان بالتالي هذا
يعني تفكك داخلي لذلك اولا يعني حكت
الاحتجاج والعصيان العسكري سوف تستمر سوف
تزداد الاحتجاج الشعبي والاجتماعي سوف
يزداد بالفتره الاخيره لمصلحه امريكا وجود
علاقات استراتيجيه مع حليفه المهمه في تلك
المطلقه من العالم
الخطر الاول ان نتنياهو قد يلجا الى
افتعال حرب باي شكل من الاشكال كي يخمد
المعارضه في اسرائيل الامر الثاني طبعا
الان مشروعهم الاساسي هو استكمال عمليه
الضم والتهويد للضفه الغربيه وتكريس نظام
الابرتايد العنصري قد نشت خلال الفتره
المقبله بدون ضغوط امريكيه في الساده على
اسرائيل من اجل الا تمر هذه التعديلات
بشكل اكثر فداحه من الان في حاله الاحتقان
الاجتماعي والسياسه في داخل اسرائيل سوف
تستمر بهذه الفتره